[Music]
most like that happened like somebody
please somebody else needs to see this
with me any witnesses you and JC Chasse
how did that come together uh yeah you
know I I threw a fun little st. Patty's
Day party and we had a lot of really fun
guests and we've thrown a couple of them
they're always very dl very no social
media when i found out who was gonna be
seeing with us i was like yep get your
phones out this is the coolest thing
ever
it's around the 20-year anniversary of
that first album that NSYNC put out so
there was kind of a 90s theme to our
party so we were celebrating a great 90s
record great nineties artists and JC's
amazing voice and I can't believe he
said yes I was like I was trying to be
nice and have him sing something else
they don't want to you know put him in a
corner and he's like no I'd rather do
something know the words to I'm like
fine I'd be very happy and you make a
lot of people this party very happy so
that was very cool when Darren Criss
isn't singing with the best of them he's
acting earning rave reviews for his
portrayal of serial killer Andrew
Cunanan
on the assassination of Gianni Versace
American crime story I tell people what
they need to hear
versace has invited me to the Opera what
would that recognition mean to you an
award or a nomination for this part it
would be very heartening for the work as
a whole it's cuz you know we put a lot
of love and care into this so if that
resonated with certainly arbiters of of
taste and and accolades then then that
would be very encouraging and validating
for our hard work well everyone is
talking about your performance there was
also a headline this week about your
butt was there saying it deserved its
own Emmy well that's maybe the one thing
we should campaign for is having its own
category although I think I would lose I
don't know that that article is pretty
convincing you should read it I don't
know I've watched Game of Thrones I feel
like I've got a lot stiff competition
what a rock hard competition no pun
intended
puns all over the place
[Music]
[Applause]